(light music)
- [Gary] I'm scared.
I'm scared because
I know that there
are so many of you
that graduate this month
and have no
(record scratching) idea what
you want to do.
I'm scared that
you don't realize
that you're entering
the greatest five year
window of your life.
This next five year
window is when
you don't go practical and safe.
This is not the time to get
the job mom wanted you to.
This is the time to
be massively risk oriented
and not all of you,
I'm sure one of you
will leave a comment saying,
"I've got a loan."
I get it, respect.
But that loan is gonna
be there whether you
go and try to build something
for yourself or not.
One way or the other,
when you're in your
early 20s this is
when you can grind
at your highest levels
'cause there isn't
all the (record scratch) baggage
that comes across with life.
(bell bings)